in this episode of cloud performance
atlas I helped some IOT visionaries come
to terms with load balancer performance
well their bet on the future of
technology pay off stay tuned to find
out
IOT roulette is a company which offers a
scalable way for IOT devices to connect
with cloud backends through a common and
simple SDK and transport layer a few
weeks ago I met with their CEO to talk
about the biggest thing on her mind
what's the performance overhead of using
Jeep's EPS load balancer as you can
imagine scale is really important to IOT
roulette with an estimated 50 billion
IOT devices in the world by 2020 scaling
your services to handle the sudden load
of a million new devices is an important
feature so fast performing load
balancers are crucial to get this right
but before we start talking about the
balancers we need to see how things
perform directly to get a baseline
performance we set up an instance in US
central and kicked off a bunch of curl
commands from a machine in Europe now if
you do this test yourself you'll notice
that the curl performance can end up
being double what the ping time is
simply due to the overhead of TCP
handshakes involved in the transfer of
the fetched data now Google cloud
platform provides two primary load
balancers so we need to understand the
difference and profile each one
individually the first is a TCP UDP load
balancer which acts much like you'd
expect a request comes in from the
client to the load balancer and is
forwarded along to the backend directly
the HTTP load balancer on the other hand
has some serious magic going on it
proxies traffic through Google front end
servers first which stops the session on
the public Internet and continues on
using Google's private network so
depending on which balance you're using
we should expect different set of
performance characteristics to test this
we set up instance groups for each
balancer in the US central region and
had a load generator in Europe fetch
from them using the same curl commands
as before the results show some
interesting characteristics first the
TCP balancer shows very similar results
to the direct access version this is
somewhat expected in this case traffic
moves from the user to the load
balancers which are in the region where
the VMS are located as such performance
is a factor of the distance from the
requester to the closest entry in the
target region just like directly
accessing the VM
hdtb balance or on the other hand did
something I really wasn't expecting
according to this test it appears to
help or mow the direct connection and
the TCP balancer this is odd since the
HTTP load balancer effectively adds
another hop to each fetch instead of
going from the clients to the balancer
to the backend it has the intermediate
step of hitting the front-end boxes
first now at first glance this seems
confusing about why adding an extra hop
would improve performance but once we
look under the hood we can quickly see
why this works see when a request hits
the HTTP bouncer the TCP session stops
there the GSEs then move the request
onto the private network and all further
interactions happen between the GFE and
your specific back-end now here's the
important part
after a GFE connects to a back-end to
handle the request it keeps that
connection open this means that future
requests from this GFE to this specific
back-end will not need the overhead of
committed creating a connection and
instead can actually just go to sending
data ASAP the result of this setup means
that the first query that causes the GFE
to open a connection to the back-end
will see slightly higher response times
those are the spikes in the front of the
graph however subsequent packets rather
the same back-end will see a lower
minimum latency so for IOT roulette this
is fantastic
the more IOT devices they get in a
region the better their HTTP load
balancers will perform not a bad bet to
make if you'd like more details on this
problem check out the full article
linked in the description below and make
sure to subscribe to our google cloud
youtube channel to get alerts when new
performance videos comes out because
don't forget when it comes to
performance every millisecond counts